COPP.
THE TRADE DEADLINE MAKES SWEET
LITTTTJARVIS THE ONE-TIMER.
FOR SETH JARVIS AS DEANGELO
JARVIS SWITCHES THE
PENALTY AGAINST AND 2-0 LEAD EIS
IN.
MAKES THIS AVAILABLE.
THE CANESSSTERKIN.
THE CANES TRYING TO ANSWER
QUICKLY.
M IGOR
SHESTERKIN.
PANARIN.
HAS IT BACK.
TRYING TO ROB AROUND.
E WRAPAROUND BY STROME, THE
SHORT SIDE BYREBOUND LEFTADE TH.
AT MADISON SQUARE
GARDEN.
A SHOT BY NIEDERREITER.
NEW
YORK, WITHLOOK,AND SHESTERKIN AT
LOOK EASY.
DOORSTEP,ON THE BACKHAND.
4-0OMING ALIVE IN GAME
SEVEN.
YOU CAN SEE HIS BODY JUST SAID.
ANY HOPE THAT CAROLINA HAD T T E
'.
GET THEM WITHIN THREE
WITH 3:47 TO GONOBODYANDREW COP.
INSTEAD OF DIRECTING THE PASS,
HE LOFTED IT IN FRONT.